is a terrible day on this tuesday there
are new details that are emerging about
the horrific moments when a gunman
opened fire
at a colorado supermarket everybody goes
to the supermarket 10 people were killed
at king super super's location in
boulder during the second mass shooting
in this country in less than a week
thank you tony a suspect is in custody
but we don't yet know his name and we
certainly do not know his motive
one of the victims was a police officer
eric talley
who was reportedly the first to respond
last night boulder came together for a
procession
in his honor tally had served since 2010
he leaves behind a wife and seven
children
omar via franca is in boulder near where
the shooting took place omar what have
you learned
good morning anthony witnesses are
starting to tell us and they're
describing the scene as
complete chaos when the shooting started
police started getting calls around
2 30 p.m at this king supers market
behind me
of shots fired we want to warn you some
of the video we're about to show you
is disturbing he went in the store
oh my god guys we got people down inside
king supers
look holy
a live stream of the shooting shows what
appears to be victims
both in and outside the building as
witnesses scrambled
there's a shooter active shooter get
away
get back i didn't realize there were
gunshots at first and
i looked outside to see what it was and
witnessed the beginning of the shooting
from from my window
anna hayes lives directly across from
king supers
he was on one of the handicapped ramps
going up to the entrance of the king
supers and he was shooting down
at something which i believe was another
person
and after he was done shooting he ran
inside the building
swat vehicles hundreds of police
officers and at least three medical
helicopters responded to the scene
but the first was boulder police officer
eric talley
one of the 10 killed in the attack his
sister saying in a tweet
that her heart is broken and she cannot
explain how beautiful he was
the heroic action of this officer
officer tally responded to the scene was
the first on the scene
and he was fatally shot inside the store
ryan borowski told our denver station
kcnc tv
no one knew what was going on heard
you know one loud bang thought somebody
just dropped something an employee or
something and then another
and then by the third one everybody was
running he and others
escaped through the loading dock so just
at that point it was just run get out of
there tell everybody to leave
and yeah that's what we had to do
newlyweds nevin and quinlan sloan were
also inside when they heard the gunshots
i pushed up on the emergency door i
think we were the first to
be out he said he helped people exit
from the back of the store
i was like dan this guy could like come
out and start shooting these guys i want
to make sure they're like as far away as
they can be stephen mchugh's son-in-law
and grandchildren were at the store's
pharmacy to get a covet vaccine
and hid for more than an hour the
shooter came in
shot the woman in front of them they had
ran upstairs or hiding in a coat closet
for the last
hour several people who had been
sheltering inside the king supers
were escorted out by officers half a
dozen
cops came in through the roof got them
and then
told them you know stay quiet and they
are okay
police say the suspect is in custody and
is injured we want to show you some
video right now police brought
this man out of the store in handcuffs
you can see there is some blood
on his leg they are not confirming if
this man is the suspect
they are also not releasing any
information about a possible motive and
tony
we're hoping to learn a little bit more
at a press conference at 8 30 a.m local
time here in boulder all right omar
we'll be monitoring that
i keep thinking about officer talley
this is what patrol officers do you're
driving around you get a call
shots fired and you go and the protocol
is that you go and you engage
yeah because people could be dying on
you wait outside and you don't wait you
don't we had seven children seven
children the youngest is seven
it's heartbreaking he only joined the
force when he was 40 and now he's 15. he
left another career he was in i.t
and he wanted to be a policeman and he
gave up a very lucrative career to be a
cop